- Actually, no.
Speaking of your family and your heritage,
you actually just celebrated Diwali
- Yes.
- [Derek] With a few
of your friends, Lilly Singh,
Kal Penn, and Priyanka Chopra.
- [Kunal] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- [Derek] And for those of you
who don't know what that is,
what, explain to them what
that celebration is like
and what the party's like.
- Basically, Diwali is
the Festival of Light.
Like, it's our Indian
Christmas, basically,
and we drink whiskey and we gamble
- [Derek] Oh, wow!
- and we like things on fire.
(both laugh)
- [Derek] These pictures are incredible.
- [Kunal] Exactly.
We dance and we have
a great time together.
And you know, I've been here,
when I started throwing
Diwali parties in 2006,
there weren't a lot of Indians, you know,
doing it at the same time.
And now,
- [Derek] Yeah?
- [Kunal] everyone is throwing this most
lavish Diwali parties.
- [Derek] Oh man.
- And it's like,
the Bollywood-Hollywood Diwali party war.
- That's amazing.
- You know,
what started as a small
gathering of people
has now turned into these most amazing,
beautiful, brilliant parties.
So my budget keeps going up
and I'm thinking next year,
we'll just have every Indian
together at one party.
- [Derek] I love it.
Could I go to something
like that if it happens, or-
- We'll charged you a cover fee, but,
- [Derek] Oh yeah? Okay.
(Kunal Laughing)
- Only because, only because
the dancing looks so much fun.
- You'd, you'd love it, you must come.